[Musique]
le triste cortège des shadoks avance
péniblement dans le cosmos le plus grave
problème reste celui du logement le
moindre fait un repas c'est qui flottait
le moindre fil de fer devait un
supporter des centaines et ça souvent
sur plusieurs étages
il y avait des shadoks qui servait de
plafond des shadoks qui servait de
plancher à ceux qui servaient plafond et
des shadoks qui servait de cloisons et
dans les interstices laissés libres la
vie à bord petit à petit s'organiser
elle s'organisait mal mais elle
s'organisait tout de même
pendant ce temps là naturellement il se
reproduisait
[Musique]
à
alors il en tombe est bien sûr mais il
n'en tombe est pas du tout suffisamment
et la nourriture manquent et certains
essayer de pêcher des choses dans le
néant
d'autres désespérés manger les
ustensiles qui les supporters
[Musique]
plus il avançait plus si longtemps mais
les gimmicks de leur côté continuer à
sillonner l'espace pour retrouver le
chapeau djiby fou vous avez scruté par
tous avec le radar mais ils n'avaient
rien trouvé
il veut aussi commençait à désespérer
[Musique]